[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hello again yes we continue
our saga
yes so uh i'll open with a word of
prayer and then we can start
our heavenly father we want to thank you
that we can get together again
we ask that you enlighten us again with
the holy spirit
and bless this discussion in jesus name
amen amen
every time we say we're going to be
bearers of good
news and every time it just
doesn't work out quite that way
so we'll have to we'll have to
concentrate on some promises somewhere
along the line
yes yes it's a a huge
issue that we're facing in the world and
i guess we just have to
take the plunge and work our way through
it right correct
so i see we've titled this one peace and
safety and uh that that tells us a lot
yeah there's a lot of peace talk
been in the last two weeks yes and we're
definitely going to discuss that
and what the bible says is it really
peace and safety
we have to we have to couple it to the
bible and we have to see
where we're going with this
so let's have a look
i thought that we would have to start
with a biblical perspective
now many of the issues that we're going
to talk about
concerning the end are written in the
book of ezekiel
of course that was a typical study yes
but it has application to the
anti-typical
so we have to see what the day of wrath
of the lord
is in this particular case he's using
jerusalem
and the fall of jerusalem to babylon as
an example
and then the promise of the remnant and
the restoration
and the issues that were
prevalent in that time are also going to
be prevalent at the end of time
so when we go to the book of ezekiel
we're not going to go through the entire
book of ezekiel i wish we could
but that would take a long long time
so we'll start with chapter 7 and jump
around a little bit
and see what the bible has to say
ezekiel chapter 7
talks about the day of the wrath of the
lord
moreover the word of the lord came unto
me saying
also thou son of man thus says the lord
god
unto the land of israel and end
the end is come upon the four corners of
the land so we're talking about an end
time prophecy
now is the end come upon thee and i will
send mine anger upon thee and will judge
thee according to thy ways and will
recompense upon thee
all thy abominations
and my eyes shall not spare thee neither
will i have
pity but i will recompense thy ways upon
thee
and thy abomination shall be in the
midst of thee and you shall know that
i am the lord
thus says the lord god and evil and only
evil behold is come
an end is come the end is come
it watches for thee behold it is come
so it's definitely talking about the end
typically
the time for the destruction of
jerusalem had come
anti-typically because jerusalem is the
type of the world
the end of the world is coming and he's
talking to his people
he's talking to god's people he's
talking to the church
and this is a very serious issue
now here's a quote from the book
maranatha and
it quotes ezekiel chapter 7 verse 5 and
about this beginning of the end and it
said fearful is the issue to which the
world is to be brought
the powers of earth uniting to war
against the commandments of god
will decree that all both small and
great rich and poor free and bond
shall conform to the customs of the
church by observance
of the false sabbath so the issue is the
commandments of god
yes all who refuse compliance will be
visited with
civil penalties and it will finally be
declared that they are deserving of
death
we read that in revelation chapter 13.
and on the other hand the law of god in
joining the creator's rest day demands
obedience and threatens wrath against
all who transgress its precepts with the
issue thus clearly brought before him
whosoever shall trample upon god's law
to obey a human enactment
receives the mark of the beast he
accepts the sign of allegiance to the
power which he chooses to obey
instead of god that's the issue
now we can find this issue also very
clearly in the bible here are they that
keep the commandments
if you want the right to the tree of
life yes commandments i mean the
commandments are
everywhere i have not come to abolish
the law says jesus i've come to fulfill
it not one jot
or one tittle will by any means
disappear from the law
i mean they are just yeah do we make
void the law
so you establish it in many many verses
dealing with this issue so we're dealing
with
obedience to god as opposed to
disobedience
now ezekiel chapter 9 is a
very solemn chapter it deals
with the sealing of of god's people
and what happens to those that are not
sealed
and it is a rather solemn issue
so we will go through ezekiel chapter 9
so that we can put it into the context
of the times in which we are living
chapter 9 verse 1 he cried also in mine
ears with a loud voice saying cause them
that have
charge over the city talking about
jerusalem
to draw near even every man with his
destroying
weapon in his hand and behold
six men came from the way
of the higher it's interesting that he
uses the number six
because six is also the number of
another opponent of god in fact he likes
three of them
six six six yes so destruction
comes in the form of six men
so these six men came from the way of
the higher gate which lieth towards the
north
that's also interesting so we know that
destruction comes from the north
but we know that there is a king who
tries to occupy the north
and the north of course is the place of
the throne of god so here you have this
antichrist power who sits in the temple
of god pretending that he is god
and he sits on the side of the north he
is occupying the side of the north
when you go to a masonic lodge the north
is also a very interesting
component so anyway
and every man a slaughter weapon in his
hand and one man
among them so there were the six plus
another
and he was clothed with linen which
means he represents
the righteousness of christ
with the writers incorn by his side so
he's going to
take notes he's going to mark down
something very
important and they went in and stood
beside the brazen altar
and the glory of the god of israel was
gone up from the cherub
where upon he was to the threshold of
the house and he called to the man
clothed with linen
which had the writers incorn by his side
and the lord said unto him go through
the midst of the city through the midst
of jerusalem
and set a mark upon the forehead of the
men that
sigh and that cry for all the
abominations that be done
in the midst thereof here's our first
clue
now this mark is a mark that god
places yes on the far right right
and the forehead is the place of your
decision making
decision making this is the frontal lobe
this is your
cognitive center so that's where you
make decisions now who receives the mark
those that cry for all the abominations
that be done
in the midst of the church
so all is not well in the church there
are many things that are wrong
and there are people in the church who
see it
and they are grieved to their call
they receive the mark those that are
careless and don't see
anything wrong don't receive this mock
so what happens to the others and to the
others he said in mine hearing
go ye after him through the city so
behind the one who's
more closing the mark and smite
let not your eyes spare neither have you
pity
slay utterly old and young both
mates and little children and women
but come not near any man upon whom is
the mock
and begin at my sanctuary in other words
begin
with the church with the elders in the
church
and then they began at the ancient men
which were before the house
that is leadership the leadership
of the church and he said unto them
defile the house fill the courts with
the slain go
ye forth and they went forth and slew
in the city now that's a terrible
picture
this is the picture of the final
judgment from which there is no return
and people will say now is god just when
he
says that he must you must destroy old
and young
[Music]
maids little children women
the whole lot well what happened during
the flood
you're saying the same thing so this is
the final judgment
these people obviously have had
opportunities or else god would not deal
in this fashion
but those who have consistently refused
that little voice of the holy spirit
will eventually
be destroyed yes that is what the bible
says
and it came to pass while they were
slaying them and i was left that i fell
upon my face and i cried and said ah
lord god
will thou destroy all the residue of
israel
are they all going to be destroyed in
thy pouring out of thy fury upon
jerusalem
then said he unto me the iniquity of the
house of israel
and judah is exceedingly great
now if that was typical then what would
be the
antitype of the house of israel
and the house of judah
the house of judah is the one that
clung to the precepts of god more than
the others right
so we could say that judah represents
those
that cling to god's precepts that cling
to his law
that try to live according to that
standard
they weren't very good at it always but
they at least
had the precepts right so that would be
those who keep the commandments of god
and have the testimony
and the house of israel would be
the entire protestant protestant
christian church
out there and he said the land is full
of blood
and the city full of perverseness for
they say the lord has forsaken the earth
and the lord
seeth not because god's retributive
action takes
a long time they've become complacent
and they just carry on as though god
doesn't see
and as for me also mine eyes shall not
spare neither will i have pity but i
will recompense their way upon their
head
and behold the man closed with linen
which had the incorn by his side
reported the matter saying
i have done as thou hast commanded me
so in the end there will be a repetition
of this
there will be a distinct
seal which god will place in the
forehead
of god's people in other words it is a
cognitive shift
now let's continue and see where this
leads us
so what is the seal of the living god
that will apply at the end of time
look during literal jerusalem
there was a very distinct sifting some
were taken out beforehand
and were spared like daniel and his
friends and others
some were spared within the city
jeremiah for example and some were
brutally destroyed within the city
so if we apply it to the end of time
then we have to go to the book of
revelation
chapter 7 and it says and i saw another
angel descending from the east
having the seal of the living god and he
cried with a loud voice to the four
angels to whom it was given to hurt the
earth and the sea
so here was again a destruction coming
upon the earth and upon the nations
saying hurt not the earth neither the
sea in other words don't bring the
destruction
nor the trees the individuals till we
have sealed the servants of our god
in their foreheads this is the same as
the
it's exactly i would say inkpot that's
the man with the ink on absolutely
so here we have the situation applied to
the end of time so there must come a
ceiling now we need to know
what is the seal of god
and here's a quote from the bible
commentary and it says just as soon as
the people of god are
sealed in their foreheads it is not any
seal or mark that can be seen
but a settling into the truth both
intellectually
and spiritually so they cannot be moved
just as soon as god's people are sealed
and prepared for the shaking
it will come indeed it has begun already
the
judgments of god now upon the land to
give us warning that we may
know what is coming so
to be sealed is to be so settled in the
truth
that you cannot be moved so
what is truth now we've dealt with this
many times but
just for those who have not been
part of this discussion from the
beginning
these are the definitions of truth in
the bible
john 14 6 jesus said unto them i
am the way the truth and the life no man
cometh unto the father but by me
that is a central truth salvation
is in christ and in christ alone
the second definition we find in john 17
17 sanctify them through thy truth
thy word is truth
so god's word yes you must be settled
in the truth of god's word yes no
evolutionist
may rattle you no no dispensationalist
may rattle you no thus saith the lord
thus
saith the lord psalms 119 verse 151
thou art near o lord and all thy
commandments are truth
thy righteousness is an everlasting
righteousness and thy law
is the truth that's pretty clear yes
so we have jesus central
to the truth we have the word of god
central to the truth
and we have the commandments of god
those are the issues
that's it and that's a biblical
definition now nobody can say this is an
extraneous
source this is the bible speaking
this is what truth is so if you should
say
there are other way means of salvation
other than jesus
that's not the truth no if you would say
the word is an allegory here and an
allegory
there and you don't know what is
inspired and what is
not inspired that's not truth exactly
because it definitely tells us that
every word yes that proceeds out of the
mouth of the lord right
and if somebody tells you that the
commandments are not important then
they're not speaking the truth correct
and you can quote the new testament you
can quote the old testament it doesn't
matter
those are the definitions
and we must individually know for
ourselves what is truth
you can't hide behind your church i
can't
hide behind anybody no no behind your
pastor you can't hide behind me
lord i didn't know because he said so
and he said so
okay be prepared to give a reason of the
hope that we have
with meekness and fear not in a proud
boasting self-sufficiency but with the
spirit of christ
we are nearing the time when we shall
stand individually alone to answer for
our beliefs
this is a good thing which means nobody
may mess with your mind right
correct we've discussed that we shall be
attacked on every point
we shall be tried to the utmost we do
not want to hold our faith simply
because it was handed down to us by our
fathers
such a faith will not stand the terrible
test that is before us
we want to know why we are seventh-day
adventists so what
real reason we have for coming out from
the world as a separate and distinct
people
now i know some people will say oh yeah
they go again with this seventh day
adventist thing right now
seventh day just means the bible talks
about the seventh day
the seventh day is it part of the
commandments yes are you sure
yes remember though the seventh day yeah
remember because god created the heaven
and the earth and everything in it
correct so remember the sabbath day
because
in the seventh day it was instituted at
creation absolutely
we want to know why we are commandment
keepers including the fourth
commandments and why we believe
in the second coming of christ not
in a new age an esoteric age but in
a literal coming of christ because
in john chapter 14 it tells us
absolutely plainly that he's coming
again
yes so either that's the truth or it's
not the truth
simple as that so forget about the
denominational name
look at the principle and ask is this in
harmony with the principle
and there will be a terrible shaking
ezekiel chapter 5 tells us about the
shaking
and thou son of man take thee a sharp
knife
take the ababa's razor and cause it to
pass upon thine head
and upon thy beard then take
three balances to weigh and divide the
hair
thou shalt burn with a fire
a third part in the midst of the city
i don't want to use you as an example
but
yes you are a perfect example for
for this you are perfectly shaven
and the only problem is i don't know
whether you had any hair to put on a
scale yeah i don't know if we're going
to get the
weight okay
but this is a very serious issue so he
took the air
and he was too divided and he was to
burn
with fire a third part in the midst of
the city
in jerusalem yeah so this is a reference
to jerusalem
and when the days of the seed are
fulfilled and thou shalt take
a third part and smite about it with a
knife
and a third part thou shalt scatter in
the wind
and i will draw out the sword after them
and thou shalt take thereof a few in
number
and bind them in thy skirts
now my mathematic tells me that a third
and a third and a third
is a whole soul so
[Music]
that's a pretty bad news so
mathematically
it looks like almost everybody is going
to be destroyed
now i want you to remember that when
literal jerusalem was destroyed
many had been taken out beforehand
so that's good news but even those
within the city that were there
take a few of them and bind them to thy
skirts now that's the remnant
that's going to escape all of it
let's have a look and take off them
again oh
it gets worse she's even getting fewer
yes and this this
um makes it very important to understand
that it's an individual
on an individual scale absolutely you
this is a very very use the word scale
there yeah
so what does the scale do it weighs so
you
are weighed in the balances and you are
found one pointing
and cast them in the midst of the fire
and
burn them in the fire for therefore
shall a fire come forth unto all the
house of israel
thus says the lord god this is jerusalem
i have set it in the midst of the
nations and countries that are around
the barter
so why is he so angry with them because
they transgressed the commandments
but they were in the midst of the
nations they were supposed to be an
example
exactly there was to be supposed to be a
source of evangelism
they were supposed to have educated the
entire world
but they ensconced themselves and said i
am rich and in need of
nothing who cares about my neighbor out
there if he doesn't know these things
and in any case if i tell him he'll only
get angry so i'll leave him in his
misery
that's the wrong attitude so god had set
them in the nations and they never did
their work
now what else did she do she has changed
my judgments
into wickedness more than the nations
and my statues more than the countries
that are around about they for they have
refused my judgments
and my statutes and have not walked in
them so again
the issue is obedience to god's precepts
and then this promise ezekiel chapter 6
verse 8 yet i will leave a remnant
that you may have somewhat shall escape
the sword amongst the nations
when you shall be scattered through the
countries
so when he scatters them with the sword
they're not all going to die and
they will be grateful that they survive
but they will be amongst the nations so
that they can finally do the work that
they were supposed to do in the first
place
in other words warn the nations
bring the gospel to the world
ezekiel 7 16 but they that escape
of them shall escape and shall be in the
mountains like doves of the valleys
all of them mourning everyone for his
iniquity now
this is a a very important verse
so you have this remnant and the remnant
will be scattered amongst
all the nations and
this remnant is described like
a dove that's a gentle creature right
all of them mourning everyone for his
iniquity
so there's no self-righteousness here
there's no uh
room for button-popping arrogance right
yes
pushing out your chest until the buttons
pop off and
saying i'm not like like that miserable
sod over there
look at me i'm i'm the bee's knees right
yeah
no they will know that they are
all in need of redemption yes
so the closer you come to christ the
more sinful
you appear in your own eyes yes
and this is important for salvation in
other words we must
realize what our situation is if you
don't realize what your situation is
why would you seek help
and who's the only one who can help you
only god only god can help you
now why is this judgment so severe
what are they doing we need to know
because we want to put this into a
modern context right
this is what we are doing
ezekiel 8 13 he said also unto me
turn ye yet again and thou shalt see
greater abominations that they do so
there's a long list of abominations
listed in ezekiel we're just going to
highlight
the very important ones there's 14.
then he brought me to the door of the
gate of the lord's house
which was towards the north again we're
talking about the throne of god
the very heart of worship
peace and behold there said women
weeping for tamus what are they doing
there
in other words within god's
church where the north represents the
throne of god
there are actually people that
weep for tamus now tammuz
was the sun
and uh sun with a s o in
and the ancient babylonian religion
was of course baal worship and you had
mother and child worship
you had semi-ramos and semi-ramos was
the the virgin mother if you like
and she had this child tamus
and he is the one that was also
eventually
sacrificed so instead of
looking at it in the christian sense
this is a
paganized form of worship yes
so it's babylonian wine
now mother and child worship where do we
find that in the world today
roman catholicism in roman catholicism
and if you align yourself with that kind
of worship
then aren't you worshiping a false
system
yes then you are worshiping the beast
all right so that is one of their great
problems that they have
a babylonian concept of religion
can that also mean
if they say they sat woman weeping for
them is going to be the other churches
yes that's also women is plural and
women in the bible is a church
so the churches had a babylonian form of
religion
without really knowing with it so as
soon as you have a ritualized religion
with candles and and proceedings and
activities
uh to get the attention of god then you
have a problem
it's interesting when uh johann huss
when he was beginning to preach and he
was a catholic priest as you know the
first thing
that the roman catholic church was did
was to forbid them using the mass
because one of the things that he said
that johannes said
was that you have to have both kinds you
have to have the bread
and the wine and catholicism only had it
in one kind right
and so they forbade them from
performing the mass and they forbade
them
from partaking in any of the sex
sacraments which were all rituals right
and so what happened was the only thing
that was left was the preaching of the
word
and that was the truth so first
god saw to it that everything was
stripped away that was ritualistic and
that was babylonian
and left them only with the word and
then they got to the truth
that's amazing yes wow
so then he brought me into the inner
court of the lord's house verse 16
and behold at the door of the temple of
the lord between the
ports and the altar were about
five and twenty men these are the elders
the leaders of the church but they had
their backs towards the temple
and their faces towards the east
could it be that even in a modern
context
we can have similar things that
the church will even allow
eastern mysticism to enter into the
church
yes could it be could we have a
spiritual formation and eastern
mysticism
entering in via the back door
and that people are actually worshiping
towards the east
in other words sun worship babylonian
worship
and pedaling it off as the worship of
god
yes and they worship the sun towards the
east
so what is the problem with the church
in the end time the church is at fault
because it has babylonian
rituals and they have eastern mysticism
now the exercises of loyola for example
based on pure eastern mysticism yes
eventually there's no difference between
eastern religion with eastern meditative
religious forms and what is happening
there
and then you have of course the word of
god
still there but not used for what it
says
lectio divina divine reading
it's how you read it and the poetic form
in which you
say it and and how you sing it
you must have your senses come alive in
it
smell and all of these things and in
some religions
the way in which you sing it is so
important that
the singing style of the word becomes
more important than
what the word says now we must live on
every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of god
and you cannot ritualize it then you
have eastern religion
serious issues happening in the church
in all of them unfortunately yes
ezekiel chapter 11 and then he said unto
me son of man
these are the men that's the 24
or about 25 elders
that devise mischief and they give
wicked counsel in this city all right
now
we want to know what is the wicked
council yes
which say it is not near
that's a serious issue and you know the
lord jesus
also had a number of parables
where he said that the people say it's
not near yes
no and then he starts beating his
brother and his sister because you know
the lord's coming is not near
if you do not have a message of the
nearness of the coming of the lord
in every generation particularly
in this one you're in serious trouble
god does not look on it
with a smiling face so what is it that
is this wicked counsel they say
it's it's not near it's not here it's
this is just
a it's just a glitch on the road yeah
it's
happened before we've been similar
this city is the cauldron and we be the
flesh
it's interesting that he actually takes
them out
and destroys them outside the city in
other words
uh in the book of ezekiel there's a
spitting out yeah it's like a
it's not the city survives yes i
cancel you to buy from me gold yeah
that's right
and if you don't i will spew you out of
my mouth so here in the book of ezekiel
there's also spewing out
chapter 12 22 son of man what is that
proverb
that you have in the land of israel
saying the days are prolonged
it's not time for the lord to come no
no there's so many things that must all
happen
and every vision phaleth i mean we've
said this for years why should it now be
the real thing
right tell them therefore that says the
lord god i will make this proverb to
cease and they shall no more use it as a
proverb in
israel but say unto them the days are at
hand
and the effect of every vision
if we then go to 1 thessalonians 5 3 we
see exactly the same thing and when they
shall say
peace and safety then sudden destruction
cometh upon them as
travail upon a woman with child
and they shall not escape that's our
background
so now we have to see what this looks
like in a modern context
yes yes how it pertains to what's
happening around us it's an
amazing prophecy the book of ezekiel
is it is the end time
events and if you if you take the book
of ezekiel
and jeremiah and the book of revelation
it reads like a modern movie script
of reality correct not jesuit theater
now remember that we spoke about this on
a number of occasions
national ruin follows national apostasy
now we've just read about
apostasy right
isaiah 24 5 the earth also
is defiled under the inhabitants thereof
now what is it again it's always the
same issue
because they have transgressed the laws
changed the ordinance broken the
everlasting covenant that's the issue
and that's the thing it's the same issue
from the beginning actually if you take
it adam and eve
had the same problem that's why
it hasn't changed no so they
there's no they did it differently in
the old testament and the new testament
there was
the biggest critique out there is that
people say oh you always with your
commandments you're
always with us and always with that why
don't they read the bible
that's what it says right they want to
tear out the whole old testament but
because that talks about the
commandments but you'll have to tear out
the new testament
exactly the people of the united states
have been favored people
but when they restrict religious liberty
surrender protestantism
and give countenance to potpourri in
other words
start weeping for times walking around
with little
statues etc then you're gonna have a
problem right exactly
the measure of their guilt will be full
and national apostasy will be registered
in the books of heaven the result of
this apostate will be national rune now
we've
talked about those issues and we saw
where it would lead
and that there will be a destruction yes
so what is our only hope
cling to the lord cling to the lord
by the decree enforcing the institution
of the papacy
in violation of the law of god
our nation will disconnect herself fully
from righteousness
when protestantism shall stretch her
hand across the gulf to grasp the hand
of the roman
power when she shall reach over the
abbess to
clasp the hands with spiritualism
then under the influence of this
three-fold union our country
shall repudiate every principle of its
constitution as a protestant and
republican government
and shall make provision for the
propagation of papal falsehoods and
delusions
then we'll have the women weeping for
tamus
then we may know that the time has come
for the marvelous working of
satan and that the end is near
so bible is so specific it even tells us
that the women the churches are going to
bake little buns for the queen of heaven
and that little bun used to be a round
bun with a cross on it
so we call it today a hot cross bun
at the same time anarchy is seeking to
sweep away
all law not only divine
but human the centralizing of wealth and
power the vast combination for the
enriching of the few at the expense of
the many
the combinations of the poorer classes
for the defense of their interests and
claims the spirit of unrest
of riot and bloodshed the worldwide
dissemination of the same
teachings that led to the french
revolution
all are tending to involve the whole
world in a struggle similar to that
which convulsed france
now we've had that discussion yes a
number of times
but this has now set the stage so that
we can see
where we are heading in the times that
we are living in so can we see all of
these things happening in the world
today
yes um does that not give you if you
read this and you
can see it happening then
that surely that must give you um
some surety that this is not false
prophecy
exactly now many many years
i said that issues will return that are
similar to the french revolution and
that we might see some guillotines
around again
and people were you know saying that
this is pathetic where do you come
across
something like that but it's amazing how
it happens
now we spoke about the town crier yes
remember
at the destruction of jerusalem in 70
a.d which was the the
type for the destruction of the world
there was this town crier who for seven
years
said whoa whoa to the city of jerusalem
and we showed him in the last what's up
for our modern time
and we said that he preached for three
and a half years remember
and then we also said well if you've
been preaching for three and a half
years
and if there's any correlation not that
we want to make a correlation because
then we get into trouble
nevertheless that means seven years
will be up if he should be
the same the antithesis of
that particular town crier so we don't
want to go there
and what we also asked is with the
protests
yes we asked what if somebody goes
and evangelize among them exactly what
would happen yeah it's interesting that
this man
actually did that right so we can see
how
he was treated now this is his ministry
this
and his ministry is torch of christ
ministries and this is what he wrote
clearly portland's protests are not just
about
peaceful innocent moms and dads
the media is lying to you and there's a
clear agenda the truth is
far from what is being told we
experienced
complete hatred towards us for
apparently no other reason
than being perceived as opposition
and against their end goals
and motives so they went there and they
received
terrible opposition
now he's not a aggressive person he's a
he's a gentleman now he's
also not alone when he in his ministry
he is a white man but his camera crew
consists of black people
so they go together and they're friends
when they do so
it's not a racial thing for them
right here torch of christ ministries
fully stands for bringing a complete and
total end to every type of racial
injustice prejudice and bigotry the
problem with many of the protests
ongoing in portland seattle and other
places is that they are being
perpetuated
largely by white anarchists hiding
behind masks
they are using the movement towards
racial equality as a means to reach
their
own nefarious goals of creating chaos
destruction and hostility towards
authority or law
remember rebellion lawlessness
anarchy i find it amazing that those
words are all there
and disrespect towards all governing
bodies
is the substance of their movement
so this movement wants to get rid of all
law
human and divine
so that's a fulfillment of prophecy
definitely
definitely now let's have a look at what
he actually
experienced right
my friends we have to stand up for
what's right i'm here to protest sin
i'm going to protest lawlessness and
anarchy hatred
we have to stop hating each other we
have to start loving each other
that starts when jesus takes your heart
of flesh
and he gives you a new heart
[Music]
we must call out to jesus
all right let's go let's go
all right all right god loves you repent
for the kingdom of god has come here to
you repent
go you are a threat to our community we
are not you
this is how you live your life
intimidation you're using intimidation
you're using fear tactics you're using
violence
you're using hatred you hate me for you
don't even know why are you touching
them
you are a threat to our community when
he says
we must love each other that's
interesting
yeah that was actually get out go go
go you're not welcome so
our town crier tried to calm them down
or try to tell them that they must love
each other and
donald trump recently had a little talk
with the media
where he says that you know this thing
won't go away if you
if you have this kind of ideology
so let's just hear what he had to say to
the media how will a trumpet he will
probably
why why won't he calm things down biden
won't calm things down
they will take over they will have won
if biden gets in
they will have one he's a weak person
he's controlled like a puppet
so it's not going to be calm things down
it's going to be they will have won they
will have taken over your cities
it's a revolution you understand that
it's a revolution
and the people of this country will not
stand for that they're not going to
stand for that
the vast majority of people feel like me
they feel like
every time i put law and order up on
social media it gets
such an incredibly positive response
the people of this country will not
stand for it if you say calm things down
yeah
calm things down because they will have
taken over take a look at what's going
on
and biden well biden is i don't even
like to mention biden because he's not
controlling anything
who do you think is pulling biden's
strings uh is it former obama
people that you've never heard of people
that are in the dark shadows
people that what does that mean that
sounds like conspiracy theory dark
shadows
people that you haven't heard of they're
people that are on the streets they're
people that are controlling the streets
we had somebody get on a plane from a
certain city this weekend
and in the plane it was almost
completely loaded with
with thugs wearing these dark uniforms
black uniforms with gear and this and
that they're
they're on a plane where's the world
i'll tell you sometime but
it's under investigation right now but
they came from a
certain city and this person was coming
to the republican national convention
and there were like seven people on the
plane like this person
and then a lot of people were on the
plane to do big damage
they were coming planning for washington
yeah this was all this
is all happening but the money is coming
from somewhere money is coming
how can it be from some very stupid rich
people that have no idea that
if their thing ever succeeded which it
won't they will be
thrown to the wolves like you've never
seen before on the flu vaccines in
massachusetts they're mandating that
children get
flu vaccines in order to go back to
school there's a controversy about that
a lot of parents like
whoa we you know we don't we don't want
our kids get the flu vaccines
are you worried that on the push for
vaccines these fast vaccines for covet
you might be splitting a coalition of
americans frankly in both parties
who aren't comfortable well once you get
to a certain number you know we use the
word heard
right once you get to a certain number
it's going to go away so you know it
doesn't have to be
but yeah i mean a lot of people are not
going to want to do it a lot of people
don't want to
do the flu should it be mandatory you
know i never had the flu but i never had
a shot i never had the vaccine
i come here the first thing sir you have
to have a flu shot
i said why because you have to have it i
say what's the percentage and
i wasn't thrilled with the percentage
you know it's like fifty percent
fifty-five
but dr fauci said it might not give
quote great protection
because it's a coronavirus well i said
look if i've never had it wouldn't it be
good
and then i thought i should have it
because i'll set an example so i had it
so i've had it now
three times but and i still haven't had
the flu
so maybe i'll give credit to the flu
vaccine i don't know if i can say this
you'll
you'll uh i think we're gonna have a
vaccine very soon
a lot of tremendous work has been done
you're gonna have a vaccine just like we
have therapeutics which to me are even
more important you go into the hospital
yet make people better that's to me the
most
but and we just did the convalescent
plasma
i think and you have other things too so
i think we're gonna have a lot of
therapeutics and we're gonna have a
vaccine very soon
as to whether or not people take it 35
say they're not going to take the coven
vaccine they don't want it they
shouldn't be manchester but if you add
35 to the people that have had it and to
all of the other things you know people
that have had it where in theory you
can't get it although they found
one person and they're making a big deal
one person got it twice
but if you add it all up it it gives you
very good protection
if you had to do it all again i know
that's kind of a hard question but
do it all again would you put fouchy
front and center
every day in charge of the coronavirus
task force
i get along with him very well i
disagree with a lot of what he said he
said keep it
open for china that was a big mistake
and he admits it
uh i just i get along with him but every
once in a while he'll come up with one
that i say where did that come
from i inherited him he was here he was
a part of this
huge piece of machine i didn't put
anybody in charge he was here he was
he's been here for 40 years 84 198 okay
he's been here for many many years uh
but and i you know you inherit a lot of
people it's part of the machinery
and you have some you love some you
don't i like them i don't agree with
them
that often but i like them right there
were two parts to that video right
yes first part was about anarchy
what side is he taking law and order
right yes we need
law and order on the other side you have
people who want to get rid of all law
divine and human law
he stands for law and order and he says
we must get this back and then the issue
of the vaccine
there he he doesn't want to get rid of
the vaccine right no
now the vaccine again is as we said in
the last one
one that leads ultimately to a control
mechanism
it's a stepping stone that's what we
suggested in any case
so the control needs to stay in place
he wants to distance himself from the
left
but not so far that he loses control
it's interesting
now the peace and safety issue
if you want peace you have to get rid of
anarchy
so you need law and order if you want to
have a means of
enforcing it the vaccine might be a good
stepping stone
is there any other peace issue that is
in the pipeline and what was the other
issue
the other issue was that they would
reach across the gulf
yes and that they would take the hand
of wrong and give up their protestant
principles
and then act as law the precepts of rome
there's also the french revolution sites
though
and you mentioned the guillotines yes
now there's a
video we still have to all right
let's have a look at that let's have a
look at that
donald trump wrapped up the republican
national convention today with a tour de
force
at the white house it went for more than
an hour and it would have put the fear
of god into the democrats it certainly
rattled joe biden's basement
inspired trump's supporters and trolled
his opponents
and the ugliness of the responses to the
president demonstrate his effectiveness
they amplify his messages and they
increase his chances of constructing an
underdog victory for instance have a
look at these protesters
outside the white house who not only
constructed a guillotine in the street
but they pretend to behead an effigy of
the president
thereby acting out the republican script
which
warns of revolutionary violence on the
streets
if joe biden wins there were
demonstrations
protests and ongoing violent clashes
with the police
and then as the guests left horrible
abuse was meted out to any american
who dared attend this speech by their
president
[Music]
[Applause]
well he more or less summed it up right
so what do we have here
in this classic north against south
south
yes so you have the one standing for law
and order
the other standing for ano king
the anarchy ones are enacting the french
revolution
they want to get rid of all law they
want to get rid of the police they want
to get rid of law and order they want to
get rid of it all
and here you have the group that wants
law and order
and wants relations
to be you know in harmony with law
and with god as we will see so let's
look at the next one
just a few moments ago i hosted a very
special call with two friends
prime minister benjamin netanyahu of
israel
and crown prince mohammed bin zayed
of the united arab emirates where they
agreed to finalize a historical peace
agreement
everybody said this would be impossible
my first trip as president was to saudi
arabia in
may of 2017 in my speech
to the assembled leaders of 54 muslim
countries
i made clear that the problems of the
middle east can only be solved when
people of all faiths come together
to fight islamic extremism and pursue
economic
opportunity for people of all faiths
it will be known as the abraham accord
and i'd like to ask
our ambassador david friedman to please
explain why we're doing and calling it
the abraham
accord abraham as many of you know was
the father of all three great faiths
he's referred to as abraham in the
christian faith ibrahim in the muslim
faith
and abraham in the jewish faith and
no person better symbolizes
the potential for unity among all these
three great faiths
than abraham and that's why this accord
has been given that name
and now this will enable people to take
flights from dubai and abu dhabi
directly to tel aviv
muslims will be welcome in israel and
this will create
a better interfaith exchange so this is
a tremendous step forward for peace in
the world for
uh for america for for israel for abu
dhabi
and all would not have been possible
without your leadership so i just want
to thank you so much thank you jared
what a great job
so we're talking about the abrahamic
faith
it's not called christian faith right
it's not
a protestant faith now
i believe in freedom of religion
and i believe in religious liberty true
religious liberty that each person
should be able to worship according
to his conscience but i also believe
that jesus christ is the way the truth
and the life and that nobody comes to
the father
except by him right
now it's called abrahamic faith
because christianity had not been
defined as the center of that faith
and this leaves scope for religions to
be included in this great
peace accord they do not have christ
as the way the only way to salvation
the islamic faith denies that allah had
a son
there was no son jesus was just a
prophet like
muhammad and the jewish faith
is waiting for a messiah to come and the
christian faith
believes that the messiah has already
come and is coming for the second time
i have a question can two walk together
lest they agree no no
you can live side by side you can live
with in peace with someone
who does not agree with everything that
you believe in
but you cannot have an accord with them
can you
it is hard to work together when there's
a religion
involved involved absolutely so this is
a very very complex issue
but be that as it may here's a peace
accord which everybody
said would be impossible and donald
trump says this is but the beginning
it's going to become greater so
let's hear what netanyahu has to say on
this issue
thanks to president trump and the crown
prince
mohammed bin zayed i think we're
changing we're making history and we're
changing history
peace is a good thing and this piece
unites
a moderate two of the most advanced
economies in the world
israel in the united arab emirates and
two of the most moderate were fighting
uh iran and the radical uh
radicals who are trying to overthrow the
entire order in the middle east
subjugate people propagate terrorism so
this is good for peace good for security
good for prosperity i think it's good
for the united states and good for
israel
you know i think the arab countries are
coming around to see that they can't be
held hostage
by the palestinians they have their own
interests to develop peace with israel
to exchange technology uh to exchange
things like
the corona vaccine development
health infrastructure
energy all the wonders of israeli
technology and entrepreneurship that you
see both
in the gulf states and especially in the
emirates and in israel
and if we join forces we can do
wonderful things limitless things
for the benefit of our people for their
well-being and for their security
the first peace agreement between israel
and one of the gulf states
and i think the first peace agreement in
which i promulgate this
new doctrine some people call it the
netanyahu doctrine it's called
peace for peace and peace
through strength now you know peace
through strength nobody
wants to make peace with a weak country
everybody wants to make peace
with a strong country and i think that
under my leadership israel has become a
very strong country
and now you see what happened at the
united nations we used to work
just this past week giving iran
basically a
not just a free pass but they could have
a flow of weapons coming in
starting in october russia and china
between the u.s
backed resolution what does that say
about what we have or have not learned
all these years since we first started
talking about this decades ago
well first of all i i smiled because you
know the u.s
or rather the u.n disappoints us once
again well that's not a surprise
uh we in israel have been disappointed
by the u.n time and time again
but i think that this particular
decision is
absolutely scandalous peace peace
but we still have the king of the south
pushing against the king of the north
yes well we have political peace
in the pipeline now we still have to
get to reaching across the gulf right
correct
let's have a look at some of those
issues
now in 2015 the pope came to visit in
the united states but
the evangelicals had already had
meetings with the pope
right so this had all been prepared yeah
they made a
delegation to go and see the pope with
prominent big
big names and here in this article from
the christian news rick warren td jakes
joel osteen expressed
excitement over the pope francis visit
to the united states in 2015
and td jake said when i think of the
roman catholic church and their belief
in jesus
death burial and resurrection the fact
that they serve the poor
the fact that they're interested in
education there are many things that we
can gather
around and agree upon is that really
true
that is certainly anything but true
because they might believe in
in jesus but they don't believe that
jesus died for you
so they throw the atonement out of
the window the um discussion we had on
the doctrine of the serpent explains
that
absolutely and then they said
sometimes protestants think that
catholics worship mary
like she's another god but that's not
exactly catholic doctrine warren
contended people say
what are the saints all about why are
you praying to the saints
and when you understand what they mean
by what they're saying
there's a whole lot more commonality
that we have with roman catholics
there's still a real difference no doubt
about that he stated but the most
important thing is if you love jesus
we're on the same team
that's incredible even if the jesus is a
totally different jesus
to what the bible teaches right
joel osteen leader of lakewood church in
houston texas likewise expressed support
for the roman catholic pontiff this last
week in speaking with reporters now that
was in 2015
as it progressed we know that in 2017
there was of course the the reformation
commemoration
and there was the joint meeting with
protestants and catholics
and this was now the gateway to this
great
unity that they were discussing yes
and here's an interesting article and
this is now from 2021 so we've moved on
right
from then catholic lutheran
reconciliation in 2021
what was that statement when the
protestants
reach across reach across the gulf to
grab
the hand of the romans then
all right catholic lutheran
reconciliation in 2021
economical group asks pope to lift
excommunication of luther an economical
group has asked pope francis to lift the
excommunication of martin luther
and in that way open the door to a new
gesture of
catholic lutheran reconciliation
the new petition to the pontiff to
rehabilitate the legacy of the
protestant reformer was contained in a
pentecost declaration published by the
altenberg
ecumenical discussion circle a group of
german-speaking catholic and protestant
theologians that over the past two
decades
have been publishing statements on
issues around
christian unity seven months out from
the 500th anniversary of the decreed
romanum pontificum the altenberg
ecommerical group
urged pope francis to take advantage of
the date
in january i love the way they use dates
right
they're so important
next year to lift leo the 10th
excoriation of luther in the ball as
misguided debased depraved damnable
headache churches to mark 5th centenary
of the excommunication
with joint worship service in rome
i think we're heading for that clasping
the hands of rome don't you think so
definitely
so now this is 2020
this is when they're speaking about it
and in 2021
they want to have it done
here's another interesting site the u.s
bishop
if we're living in the end times you
better return to god
just in case just in case just in case
is that a good motive you think
bishop thomas tobin is urging people to
return to god just in case
the natural disasters political upheaval
and global pandemic are signs that the
end times could
be near that's a very cautious approach
rather be safe than sorry okay what does
he have to say about it
i don't subscribe to the dire forecasts
of the end times
he hasn't read the book ezekiel right i
don't think he knows about revelation
either
but with horrible wildfires out west
tropical storms and the oceans
widespread droughts a global pandemic
political divisions
anger in the streets one has to wonder
we'd better return to god
now just in case
i think we should make him the next
evangelist
hey guys just in case
now when they reach across the gulf
and they take the hand of rome ooh
protestantism
yes when they reach across the gulf and
they take the hand of rome particularly
protestant america as the leader right
then what are they going to implement
roman decrees right now here's an
interesting tweet
from donald trump happy sunday
we want god it's interesting how they
contrast the biden camp
with the trump camp yes the biden camp
doesn't want god
we want god so either way trump is at
the moment playing
king of the north roll yes
the other one is playing king of the
south roll
or many of his constituents it doesn't
matter which side
wins because eventually the king of the
north will have ascendancy right exactly
and there are many king of the north
components within
the democratic party as well so we're
not picking sites here
but for the moment yes from what we've
seen now in the media
and what's going on trump is playing
king of the north gods we
want god where do they want god back
amongst the people
back in the constitution back in the
legislature
law and order
and then he used as an example the
people of poland
this fascinated me because
he wasn't very welcome in europe for a
long time right
they thought he was a a misnomer there
was something wrong with him
and the politicians gave him the cold
shoulder
so when he was in europe and they all
gave him
very much of a cold shoulder he made a
special trip to poland
for a very special speech now this is
interesting because poland is a catholic
country right
and the pope that was so important to
the polls was pope john paul the second
right and we know that donald trump
went and visited the shrine after old
second
so there's this overture to catholicism
right
so we want to see protestantism
reaching across the gulf and embracing
catholicism yes then we want to see
a sweeping away of god's law and
implementing a law of the king of the
north
that is the papacy
so in this tweet he refers to
pope john paul ii and he writes the
people of poland the people of
america and the people etc a little over
three years ago
president trump delivered one of the
most important speeches of his
presidency
in poland yes this is the video that he
tweeted this is the video that he
tweeted so
we want to have a look at what he
actually said there because this is
becoming important
we have to put the pieces of the puzzle
together
through four decades of communist rule
poland
and the other captive nations of europe
endured a brutal campaign to demolish
freedom your faith your laws your
history
your identity indeed the very essence
of your culture and your humanity and
when the day came on june 2nd
1979 and one million
polls gathered around victory square for
their very first
mass with their polish pope
that day every communist in warsaw must
have known
that their oppressive system would soon
come crashing down they must have known
it
at the exact moment during pope john
paul ii
sermon when a million polish men women
and children
suddenly raise their voices in a single
prayer
we want god together with pope
john paul ii the polls reasserted their
identity
as a nation devoted to god you stood in
solidarity against
oppression against a cruel and wicked
system
that impoverished your cities and your
souls
and you won we can still hear
those voices that echo through his their
message
is as true today as ever
the people of poland the people of
america
and the people of europe still cry out
we want god
it's interesting that he flashed there
his visit to
john paul in this year yes the shrine
to the shrine and the issue is we want
god
back we want god now this is the cry
of his convention the republican
convention yes we want to put god back
in the center
so we have a typical king of the north
king of the south clash
the movements that are active within the
king of the south ones or black lives
matter we've discussed them we saw the
communist roots
and here he refers again to it so you
know
we are in acting daniel 11. it's amazing
amazing and in the previous episode we
also
showed that he was telling that catholic
um news agency that
he is the president for catholics
absolutely they the catholics had better
be with him
so protestantism and catholicism working
together we have to
find this link more and more
now i found the republican convention
particularly interesting
he held it of course at the white house
and this
really peeved some of the people out
there because they said what right has
he got to hold it at the white house he
should hold it somewhere else
because he's using his presidency to
further his ends
but be that as it may the fact of the
matter
is what happened there is very
interesting this constant call
back to law and order back to god
back to the bible but at the same time
reaching across the gulf
and embracing catholicism
now what happened in poland
when poland took back its power
well here we read it returning to the
bible
poland reclaims sunday as a day of rest
by the way is that a cbn
news headline that is true or is that
a false headline unfortunately it's a
false headline
absolutely because if you return to the
bible why would you reclaim sunday
there's not one verse in the bible that
says that you should keep sunday right
no
not one polish lawmakers
voted last week to reclaim sunday as a
day of rest by slowly
phasing out sunday shopping by 2020.
isn't it fascinating that donald trump
at this time should remind us
in his tweets of this very
liaison with uh with poland yes
poland is amongst the last european
countries to hold on to its christian
heritage
abortion and homosexual marriage are
still forbidden in the country of 38
million
which is predominantly catholic in the
old testament the bible teaches that
sunday is a day of rest since god
rested on the seventh day after creating
the world now if that isn't a babylonian
confusion i don't know what is
is that true no of course not of course
not
i think cbn news needs a bible study
don't you think
yep the first day of the week became the
catholic
seventh day there they've got it right
there it goes there they've got it right
and this is very
important that the world out there
should know
that the first day of the week became
the catholic seventh day
yes and a day of rest
after the resurrection of jesus christ
from the dead on sunday
we celebrate the resurrection of jesus
christ through baptism
you die to the old self yes you are
resurrected
jesus after that last week of the
triumphant entry
on the sixth day he died he
rested in the grave on the seventh day
and continued his work
on the first day he didn't rest on the
first day
2012 pope benedict said
this is important that in defending
sunday
as a day of rest one defends human
freedom
and that's interesting he noted
hard time for the family is threatened
by a sort of
dictatorship of work commitments
sunday is the day of the lord and of the
men and women the day
in which everyone must be able to be
free
free for the family free for god in
defending
sunday we defend human freedom
so we have some very important links
now let's just go to
pope francis yes because that article
was 2017 yes and they were working
working towards that complete race day
in 2020 correct now pope francis
as this catholic news agency says
pandemic is a wake-up call to care for
creation
and i remember what benedict said that
we are commemorating correction
by keeping the first day when the bible
says remember the sabbath day
to keep it holy six days shall you labor
but the seventh day is the sabbath not
the first
so pope francis released a message
tuesday for the world day of prayer
for the care of creation in which he
called for repentance for humanity's
broken
bonds with god's creation and with
others
a jubilee is a time to return to god
our loving creator we cannot live in
harmony with creation
if we are not at peace with the creator
who is the source and origin of
all things as pope benedict observed the
brutal consumption
of creation begins where god is missing
where matter has become simply material
for us where we
ourselves are the ultimate measure where
everything is simply our property he
said and he's referring to benedict
and benedict said we must restore sunday
to
honor creation and the creator
absolutely
so are we heading in that direction that
is the question
here is the message of his holiness pope
francis for the world day of prayer for
the care of creation this
is september 2020
he says i'm very pleased that the theme
chosen by the ecumenical family for the
celebration of the 2020 season of
creation
is jubilee for the earth precisely
in this year that marks the 50th
anniversary of earth day
they love their jubilees don't they and
we you remember the
document that we discussed that was a
protestant document
you believe for the earth yes now here
he's very
chuffed that they called it jubilee for
the earth
absolutely it's very tough glass being
the hands
over the gulf at time to remember we are
invited to remember
above all that creation's ultimate
destiny is to enter
into god's eternal sabbath
this journey however takes place in time
spanning the seventh day
rhythm of the week the cycle of seven
years and the great jubilee year that
comes at the end of the seventh sabbath
years
then it's a time for rest
in his wisdom god set aside the sabbath
so that the land and its inhabitants
could rest and be renewed
these days however our way of life is
pushing the planet beyond its limit
creation is groaning
in some ways the current pandemic has
led us to rediscover
simpler and sustainable lifestyles the
crisis in a sense has given us a chance
to develop
new ways of living already we can see
how the earth can recover if we allow it
to rest this issue of rest is permeates
this document
the air becomes cleaner the water
clearer the animals have returned to
many places from where they had
previously disappeared
the pandemic has brought us to a
crossroads
we must use this decisive moment to end
our superfluous and destructive goals
and activities
and to cultivate values connections and
activities that are life-giving
are we heading in that direction that
the bible says we would
yes absolutely it's the same talk that
we heard on the world economic forum as
well
exactly the same now it's interesting
that uh not all protestants are
convinced that we should reach across
the gulf to take the hand of rome right
but even many of those
have still consumed some of the
babylonian wine and are incorporating
some roman catholic doctrines
like dispensationalist doctrines that
come
directly from the roman catholic
jesuit stall yes
now what i find very interesting is that
we have to in some way get all of these
religious systems under one roof right
what can be a unifying factor that is
the question
because they have very different views
so on the one hand you have
catholicism and we'll see what
catholicism is saying
about donald trump and his wife
and the catholic component then we'll
look at
the charismatic components and then
we'll look
at some of the more conservative
protestants
now what could bind them all together
maybe a common day
yes all right let's have a look at this
let's see what the roman catholics had
to say on the issue with donald trump
melania trump i'm going to show a video
to y'all just recently talked about the
invisible
enemy that's attacking the common good
and i realize when i watch this video
that's why archbishop vegano in his
letter
to trump used the theme invisible enemy
vegano was taking a term that melania
used about a month ago
and he's using melania's language in a
letter back
to trump it's i mean big archbishop
vegano if you haven't seen the
archbishop vegano
videos i've been doing all last week
please check him out but archbishop vega
knows a genius
i just realized that over and over again
that that veganos
is really using the language of the
first lady
to communicate a message to president
donald trump and i there's also covert
messages
about the occult i talked about the
latin inscription that vegano
sent to trump in the second half of his
letter to donald trump solvay
at cuagara which is an occult adage
in latin it goes back to the freemasons
and it means to dissolve and re-congeal
and it refers to the communist goal
which is to dissolve our society
dissolve our church and then bring it
back into a monstrosity
into a anti-nation anti-life
anti-christian ultimately anti-christ
one of the things that's interesting and
i had to do a little research to find
out if this was legit
or not legit uh too legit to quit
was exorcism of the white house now
there was a guy named
let me find this guy he's protestant
begley
begley said that before when when they
won the election
and they were going to move into the
white house the first lady melania said
quote all kinds of idols gods and images
and all kinds of our
artifacts are in there that are demonic
and melania said
you've got to get all that out of there
and send some
and send in some preachers and some
priests to go in and cleanse the white
house or i will not spend
one night in it that's what begley said
so during that five hours when they were
ripping out carpets and changing drapes
there were people
in there packing up every idol the only
thing that was left
was one cross on one wall they cleaned
the white house
they had people in there anointing it
with oil and praying everywhere
so apparently that was before they moved
in now there's some people who say this
is fake news and it's not true i'm not
sure this guy says
it is true but i do know for a fact that
there was another exorcism
in this one by a catholic priest let me
pull
pull up the image here this says when
father
andrew mahana maronite exercised the
white house he took a statue of our lady
of fatima and president trump asked the
priest
if he could keep it when he first moved
in so
here we have a catholic priest father
andrew mohanna maronite
it says here that this priest exercised
the white house that means
he went in with the kazakh and stole
purple stole holy water
the pr the latin prayers went through
every single room
also with incense and praise the prayers
to drive
out satan and all of his unclean spirits
so here it is and there's the priest
notice what's in president trump's hand
a statue of our lady of fatima this
priest after does an exorcism
he gives a statue of our of the blessed
virgin mary
our lady of fatima and
trump asks can i keep it and i've been
told that that statue
is displayed in the white house one
person told me it's in the oval office i
don't know if that's true
i hope it is that'd be super cool
all right so we have a catholic view we
need a catholic exorcism of the white
house
and whether that first one took place or
not is irrelevant there was a second one
and there was a statue so we have a
statue
of semiramis and a crucifix
of tamus in the white house
now that is interesting and then of
course we have the charismatic view
and paula white being one of the um
yes charismatic and trump's spiritual
advice advisor
we have that in the white house so
that's sort of a clasping of hands
taking place in that particular
setting the leader of the bee family is
always a female known as a queen bee
she's the only female that is
fertile debra your queen bee come on
but here's what's so important she is
known for her dance
she is known for her dance and it's not
like some cute little you know
this kind of dance it's not that this
kind of dance she's known for her dance
because when she gets ready to notify
and the hive of the new source of food
she will perform a dance by vibrating
her wings her wings start going into
this
like almost uncontrollable vibration the
more
beast she gets aroused so queen b starts
going into this frenzy
and she starts going around and around
and around and she goes into vibrations
until all the bees get activated and all
the bees start going
forth and she leads the way by stirring
something up
i dare you deborah come on stir it up
right now in the name of jesus stir up
faith in others
stir it up do you think i was ashamed to
stand on the lawn of the white house
in front of the president the vice
president the flotus the nation the
press
and declare in the name of jesus i
declare right now
an end to this covert 19 what good am i
if i pray some cute little prayer
what good am i if i have some fancy
little poem or just talk about the
problem
everybody knows the problem but who's
going to come forth with the solution
stir them up stir them up come on
deborah stir them up right now
stir them up there's a whole lot of food
there's revelations some people are
eating ass's head and love's dug come on
where's my debra where's my debra
well i guess christianity has
many forms these days
i'm not sure about the name deborah i
once gave a lecture on deborah perhaps
you can add a link
i will put that and the conflict of
deborah
and that is a very interesting link
because in that particular con
conflict there was a general
that had to be eradicated and a very
nasty king that had ruled over the
people
it was an end-time scenario
but i'm not so sure whether this
union is going to be very fruitful but
nevertheless
it is part of of this reaching across
the gulf
and the third one is now serious
protestantism
that has serious issues with rome
and i have no doubt let me say this
up front i have no doubt that there are
literally thousands in all the
denominations out there whether they be
the charismatic
or the catholic or the mainline
protestant
that have a real relationship with jesus
christ and a
longing to do what is right
and many of them are very confused
not knowing is this from god or is this
not from god what does god really want
and macarthur had a very interesting
story about how he sees things so let's
just look at that one to
get a total picture of this alliance
remember the alliance was catholicism
together with protestantism and
spiritualism
and uh i think we've seen all three in
these
little video clips
and and pastor has uh the president
reached out has he responded have you
had
a conversation with him yes as a matter
of fact um
not last sunday but the sunday before he
called me
after the sunday morning service and uh
he was very
gracious and said um i just want to
thank you for taking a stand
church is essential and i'm i'm glad
you're doing what you're doing
and then we talked a little bit about
why from
certainly a biblical standpoint
christians could not
vote democratic because there's no way
that a christian can affirm the
slaughter of babies
homosexual activity homosexual marriage
or any kind of
gross immorality no way we could
you know stand behind a candidate who
was affirming transgender
behavior which of course is really the
reprobate mind of romans 1.
so i i said these things aren't even
political for us
sir i said these things are biblical
these things are
laid down by by the word of god and we
love god we
desire to honor him and upholding
righteousness in a society is what a
church is supposed to do so
i said any real true believer
is going to be on your side in this
election because it's not just an
individual it's an entire set of
policies
that christians cannot in any way affirm
a lot of things go through my mind as i
go from week to week
trying to help all of us understand
the word of god and something of the
seasons in which we
now live i haven't made really any
comments about
uh covid or
the lock down and whatever else
is going on in what is called a pandemic
i don't want to offer myself as any kind
of an expert but
a rather telling report came out this
week
and for the first time
we heard the truth the cdc
the centers for disease control which is
the national organization
government organization that is to
report to us the truth
about disease said that
in truth
six percent of the deaths that have
occurred
can be directly attributable to covid
94 percent cannot
of the 160 000 people that have died
9210 actually died from covid
there is no pandemic
[Applause]
there's another virus loose in the world
and it's the virus of deception
and the one who is behind the virus of
deception is the arch deceiver satan
himself
and it's not a surprise to me that in
the midst of all this deception
the great effort that is going on is to
shut down churches that preach the
gospel
so this is not a political speech by the
way
but it does not surprise me that they
want to
shut down those who preach the gospel
because the architects of this level of
deception
are not a part of the kingdom of heaven
they're part of the kingdom of darkness
i would say this that the papacy is the
biggest hoax ever foisted on the world
the biggest hoax ever
popes who were fornicators and bribers
and murderers and some who were good men
and in the human sense dot the landscape
of this history
and make it impossible to see in it the
work of god or any
apostolic succession
[Music]
well since my time is gone let me just
give you one other thought
it is unbiblical it is unholy and it is
arrogant
and idolatrous the pope
has the right to pronounce sentence of
deposition
against any sovereign on the planet so
says
the papacy that means the pope is the
king of the world
he can depose any king
romanism is a gigantic system of
church worship sacrament worship mary
worship saint worship image worship
relic
worship priest worship and
pope worship
the pope is in direct violation of
everything in scripture
and sets himself up as the greatest
person on earth and friends
it's not a bad guess to see the final
antichrist
as a pope so now we saw
three little sections
of what macarthur had to say
now what is interesting is in the first
one he speaks
to donald trump and he says
we cannot vote yes democrat
because that is the enemy of god
basically that's what he said so we have
again the king of the north king of the
south conflict
in this now protestantism has to reach
across the gulf
he also denies the pandemic he says
there is no pandemic
according to the center of disease
control so
he understands that it leads to
something else
he also understands that catholicism is
not biblical
correct so now how are you going to get
the serious protestant
plus the catholic together
so the third component is the
charismatic component
that is the one that the papacy has
claimed over and over again
will be the one that brings it together
because if the spirit is manifest
in both organizations then the spirit
must be the same
so that'll be the glue that glues them
together
now he might not agree with many of the
issues of roman catholicism
but he's still standing on the sunday
side yes
so the one thing that still binds them
together
is sacred sunday
and of course the immortality of the
soul
would that be enough to make an alliance
my prayer of course
is that a man who has so much knowledge
should recognize the final deception
within the deception
and come out of her my people i
pray that people like
macarthur should come out of her my
people
and understand the issue
now let us just go to the republican
convention again
and see what happened at the white house
and then we'll wrap it up
new york
[Music]
hallelujah
stand beside me
[Music]
god
that was a musical climax
to the republican convention at the
white house
i believe there was a message in that
now in daniel we read that all kinds of
music
will be used to implement
the image of the beast worship
now there were three songs that were
sung there
the one was a christian song hallelujah
with a protestant flavor the other one
was ave maria
with a distinct catholic flavor and the
other one was a political song
god be with america right so
this is a union of church
and state where protestantism
catholicism
and the state come together in a musical
union i believe that
we are in the very final moments
of earth's history i believe
the man with the incorn
is walking amongst god's people
and i pray that those that sigh and cry
for all the evil that he's done
even in a clandestine fashion
will recognize the issues involved
i want to end with ezekiel chapter 11
because there is much destruction coming
but here we have some bible promises
therefore say thus says the lord god
although i have cast them
far off amongst the heathen and although
i have
scattered them amongst the countries yet
will i be to them
as a little sanctuary in the countries
where they shall come he's talking to
god's people to that remnant
that was scattered therefore say thus
says the lord god
i will even gather you from the people
and assemble you
out of the countries where you have been
scattered and i will give you the land
of israel that was in a typical sense
in the antitypical sense he will gather
his people out of
every tribe and nation and people
and in that last plague when the world
is destroyed
he will take them up the resurrected
righteous
and the translated righteous and he will
take them and they will meet him in the
air
and they shall come to them they shall
take away all the detestable things
thereof and all the abominations thereof
from thence and i will give them one
heart
and i will put a new spirit within you
and i will take the stanley
stoney heart out of their flesh and i
will give them
a heart of flesh that's the new covenant
i will write my law in their
hearts that they may walk in my statutes
and keep my ordinances
and do them and they shall be my people
and i will be their god this is the
appeal of god
the issue is a war between
the precepts of god and the precepts of
men
it is undoubtedly so yes
the other issue of course is the
centrality of christ
the only means of salvation and jesus is
the one that have said
i have kept my father's commandments
and in the same way we should say the
same shall we close with prayer
our loving heavenly father
what a description of the end times that
we find in the book of ezekiel
and what if promise of a final
restoration of a people
that will wholeheartedly put away all
idols
there will be no statues of tamus of
semoramus in any shape or form in our
lives
we will serve a living god a resurrected
savior
and we will keep the commandments of god
and there will be
one human family
united together in truth you are the way
the truth and the life
all your commandments and your word are
truth
help us to build on that foundation
in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch
the next video click here
thank you